with a game like rocket League it's not  just about the sport it's about the  looks back to the future fans were  blessed with DeLorean DLC for their  favorite pseudo soccer game and now DC  comics readers are getting the same  treatment now this is a licensed I in we  can live with on march eight you'll be  able to grab the Batmobile from the  upcoming movie Batman V Superman dawn of  justice it looks just like the Dark  Knight's iconic car but with a dash of  that rocket League style and if you want  to show your support for DC's leading  trio you can also grab antenna flags for  batman superman and wonder woman the  best part all of that comes in a meager  two dollar package this DLC will launch  simultaneously across the ps4 xbox one  and pc versions of rocket league  meanwhile Batman V Superman hits  theaters March 25th for anything you  want to know about either of those  you're ready in the right place